within the universe of death note there
are over 15 humans who've used the
notebook at some point in the timeline
and today we're about to give each one
of them a rating out of five in case you
haven't seen the anime the Death Note is
a supernatural weapon capable of killing
Any Human by writing down their name
while picturing their face in your mind
as you'd expect the various people
who've owned the notebook have used it
in a ton of different ways and what's
interesting is that there are several
characters in the manga who we never saw
using it in the anime okay so in no
particular order the first person on
this list is seira otherwise known as
cheap Kira and he's a person who
appeared 3 years after the end of the
main series now as a quick overview of
what he did initially he received the
death note from a Shinigami called
midora who by the way loves bananas
instead of apples which I thought was
kind of interesting and after he
received the Death Note the first thing
he started doing he basically started
killing old people um now specifically
he was killing old people over the age
of 65 who had serious illnesses or
diseases and I guess seira was willing
to give them the death that they wanted
on the internet old people would be
posting on forums basically just putting
their pictures out there and saying what
their disease is and why they want to
die and seira would fulfill that request
most of the time in fact by the time he
was done Japan's life expectancy
decreased from first place in the world
all the way down to sixth place which
means seira must have killed thousands
of people to have an impact that big
that your country's life expectancy goes
from first in the world to six he may
have even killed a similar amount of
people as light to have as much of an
impact as that but in terms of seira
story eventually things got to the point
where there was a debate on Sakura TV
basically it was a group of Kira
supporters versus non-ira supporters and
at a certain moment in the debate a
bunch of young people basically started
talking about how they wanted to die as
well and he did in fact kill the people
who were asking for it because he had
the Shinigami eyes he was able to see
their names and he killed them on the
spot now that moment is what brought
about Nia so Nia was kind of watching
the whole thing and he intervened at
that moment and he basically called out
seira and and basically called him a
fraud he said that seira was a murderer
and that you know he was boring and he
just disrespect to seira is the point
Following being called out by Nia on
live TV seira then sted at the wall for
3 days and without saying a word and he
then started screaming and eventually
wrote his own name in The Death Note
after being being called out by Nia in
terms of the pros and cons of this Kira
I guess in the pros section you could
say that he did kill people who wanted
to die and who was suffering so in that
sense you know he did do a service for
certain people and another thing that
works in his favor is that mat said that
seir was solving Japan's biggest problem
which was the Aging population and its
burden on the pension system so in terms
of economics apparently seira was some
kind of benefit so that's another good
thing however moving moving on to the
downsides of seira he killed people
whose families asked for them to die now
I see a few problems with this I mean
number one I can very easily imagine a
scenario where a family wants to get an
inheritance family members can have
ulterior motives and so I feel like it
needs to come from the person themselves
another bad thing is that he killed the
young people on Sakura TV and the reason
this is bad is because they could have
maybe turned it around maybe their life
wasn't over but seira just kind of
killed them anyway um which is very
different very different situation from
elderly people who were suffering from
illnesses and who' lived the full life
you know very different very different
situation um and finally the last thing
to mention about seira is that he
couldn't handle the consequences of
being called out by by L and one funny
thing I want to contrast this with light
because you know when light and Nia had
their face off Nia said to him you know
you're nothing but a murderer he
basically said the same thing to light
and if you compare light's reaction with
seira's reaction of killing himself uh
it is very different so I guess one
thing you can say is that se Kira he he
didn't have the same level of confidence
as life and so for that reason I'm
giving him a rating of three out of five
I think that's fair but let me know in
the comments down below what you think
following this we have Aira otherwise
known as minoru Tanaka and this was the
next person to have the Death Note after
seira died at the time minoru was a
middle school student who scored the
highest in Japan's intelligence test for
three years in a row and unlike light he
was specifically chosen by ryuk to be
the one to have this notebook in case
you're wondering this is the exact same
notebook that seira had because after
his death madora took it back into the
Shinigami realm and when she got there
she kind of explained how she thought
the whole thing was boring and how she
doesn't really understand humans so she
was done with the whole thing and she
gave the notebook back to ryuk who then
decided to take it down to the human
world himself the reason he did this is
that he wanted to find an intelligent
person who'd be able to feed him apples
for as long as humanly possible and also
someone who'd be able to I guess keep
him entertained as well that's why ryuk
specifically tried to find someone who
was super intelligent and it just so
happens that minoru like I said was top
of the intelligence test for 3 years in
a row now in the beginning when they
first met ryuk does try to pressure
minoru a little bit into doing the same
kind of entertaining things as light
however what's very clear from the
beginning is that minoru didn't want to
kill anyone with the notebook at the
same time though he did still want to
make some kind of use out of it and so
he comes up with a genius plan to sell
the Death Note instead this plan is
something that had never been tried in
the history of the notebook and what I
thought was interesting about it is that
the reason he had to do the plan the way
he did and I'll explain it in a second
but the reason he did it the way he did
was because of the way that the world
had changed there were now cameras on
every street and of course on the
internet everything is tracked so minoru
didn't really have many options when it
came to selling the notebook in the end
what he did is he took advantage of of
ryuk's invisibility and he made ryuk go
to a TV station and just hold up a sign
saying that the power of Kira was for
sale now following that people went on
Twitter and they just started putting in
their bids and I think it went to at
that time I think it was around a
million but after a while the bids did
get even more serious than that when you
had countries like China and America
putting in you know billions and
billions of dollars to try and get the
death note of course I should probably
mention that even though ryuk was
invisible there some people who were
able to see him on the TV including Nia
matsuda and anyone who was there during
the final showdown from the main series
Nia's plan to catch Akira was to follow
ryuk's movements from the TV station
because he assumed that after ryuk left
the station he would probably go to
aira's location which was true however
the issue was that you can't follow a
Shinigami when they're traveling
underground underground travel obviously
means that there aren't any cctvs
following him the whole time so yeah it
was physically Ally impossible for them
to track him all the way back to
minoru's house and therefore they didn't
have a realistic way of finding him now
as the bids for the Death Note kept
increasing the king of the Shinigami
heard about this and for some reason or
the other he was super angry and he made
a brand new rule which says that if you
sell the Death Note you die when you
receive the money and if you buy the
Death Note you die when you receive the
notebook itself this was the first time
that a new rule had actually been added
to the death note and what it meant was
that when manur received the money in
the end he ended up dying on the spot
before we get into the pros and cons of
this character there are a few facts
that I wanted to mention the first is
that after his death ryuk described
Minor's plan as perfect not to mention
he was the first person to defeat Nia
since Nia became the new L Akira was
also a master of IQ tests and quizzes
but when it came to his actual school
workor he scored pretty badly but this
is probably just down to laziness like
he actually didn't really care about
that stuff anyhow in terms of the pros
and cons I guess the first good thing is
that he outsmarted near like he found a
way to not only sell the death note and
not be caught but he also received the
money in a way where it couldn't be
traced which should have been impossible
but the way he did it was pretty good
and this brings us to the second good
thing which is that in the process of
receiving his money he also helped out a
bunch of other people as well if you
haven't read this short story
essentially what happened is that Donald
Trump bid 10 trillion to buy the death
note and monor accepts this so $10
trillion Point Blank that's what he's
going to receive however in order to
kind of hide his tracks he splits up the
10 trillion between all people who meet
certain criteria the criteria that
needed to be met was that you had a
yachu savings account you lived in Tokyo
and you were under the age of 60 so all
those people would receive their equal
share of the 10 trillion and it was
genius because by doing it this way no
one would really know who Kira was all
they know is that he was one of these
hundreds of thousands of people but they
didn't know exactly who according to one
person the amount was roughly $1 million
us per person and so in that sense he
helped himself sure but he also helped a
bunch of other people as well this led
to a major boost in the Japanese economy
with people buying houses and cars and
all sorts of things and this period of
economic growth was referred to as the
Kira bubble another great thing is that
minoru's plan was so perfect that in
order to lose the Shinigami king
literally had to personally get involved
and make a brand new rule that obviously
he didn't know about so if it was n for
that divine intervention Minor's plan
would have been perfect and he would
have got his money and he would have
forgotten everything that happened with
the death note so the fact that it had
to be divine intervention that stopped
him I think that's a pro like it shows
that your plan was completely Flawless
switching over to the downsides though
minoru was so determined to forget
everything about the death note that he
specifically told ryuk he said never
show up around me again for any reason
but by being so forceful in the way he
said this it's almost like he assumed
that nothing could go wrong and when
you're dealing with the supernatural
there's always a chance that something
might screw up so I feel like he was a
bit too forceful in the way he said to
ryuk never show up for any reason and
because of that that's ultimately why he
died because ryuk was going to go back
and warn him or at least ruk thought
about it and then he realized you know
he remembered what Manu had said and he
didn't do it so yeah that was Akira's
biggest mistake that being said I do
still think aiera deserves a 4.5 out of
five overall because at the end of the
day he had a perfect plan he outsmarted
near and was the first person to do that
he had good intentions in that he didn't
want to kill anyone and he created a
little bit of economic boom in Japan so
overall his impact and his plan and his
goals put together that is definitely a
4.5 out of five flashing back to the
pilot chapter of Death Note this was a
draft of the story that was created some
time before the main series and in it
there are three characters who use the
notebook the first is Taro kagami who's
the 13-year-old protagonist the second
is his classmate miora and the third is
an unknown person who used the Death
Note back in
1979 because their stories are
interconnected we're going to rate them
at the same time but first let's do a
rundown of the pilot chapter itself okay
so the Story begins with Taro just
walking along the street and he finds a
death note on the floor and from that
moment onwards he just uses it as his
own personal diary now the reason for
this is that the Death Note is written
in English and because this is obviously
in Japan he doesn't know what the word
death means so he doesn't really think
anything of it and so when he goes home
he writes down the name of two bullies
and the next day they end up dead within
the span of 2 days he then kills a total
of five of his bullies by accident and
you know with five people dying in the
same class naturally that is suspicious
and so an investigation begins with
these two detectives looking into it
logically speaking the detectives then
tried to make certain connections
between the five kids who died and one
thing they realized is that all five
kids used to bully miora so miora is one
of the suspects as well as the main
protagonist during the course of their
investigation the detectives also
uncover a similar case from 1979 where a
bunch of employees at a specific bank
all died from either heart attacks or
sudden deaths and it all happened at
roughly the same time and then the final
death was an employee who committed
suicide what was interesting about that
final employee is that it was discovered
later on that there were other people
who knew him who also died in suspicious
circumstances so from our perspective as
an audience that was clearly someone who
had used the Death Note decades earlier
and I guess couldn't handle what they
done meanwhile when it comes to tarot he
was in a similar position in that he
literally couldn't handle the fact that
he killed five people and he's only 13
years old so naturally it's going to
have a negative effect so to help him
with this ryuk offers Taro the death
eraser the death eraser is a concept
that thankfully never made it to the
main series but the idea aidea behind it
is that if you rob out someone's name
who's written in the Death Note then you
could literally just bring them back to
life and yeah so tar rubs out the names
of the five kids and literally the next
day they just show up at school the two
detectives then show up to question the
kids and just you know find out what
happened but before the kids can say
anything they all die from heart attacks
again on the spot so like the five kids
all die in the classroom and the two
detectives as well now what was
important about this scene is that Taro
isn't the one who killed them you know
he left his death note at home so it
wasn't him we know it was someone else
in the classroom at that time but we
don't know who shortly after this the
school temporarily closes down and
around the world violent criminals start
dying from heart attacks and the story
gets so big that it makes it onto the
news we then get this scene where on TV
there are a bunch of panelists talking
about who's responsible for this and one
of them mentions that if they were
writing a story then they'd make it that
a boy was responsible because you know
the first deaths happened at a school so
it makes sense that if it was a
fictional story a boy would be the one
who started this whole thing the rest of
the panelists then start debating this
point and as soon as they start talking
about it most of them are just killed
and out of nowhere ryuk just drops the
bombshell that he had dropped his other
Death Note so as we all know you know
Shinigami if you're bringing a Death
Note to the human world it's expected
that you should have one for yourself
and one for the human and in ryu's case
he dropped both notebook so now there's
someone else out there who has the
second death note Tara then comes to the
realization that the other user has to
be meora because number one he was the
only other person being suspected by the
detectives and number two he fits the
criteria that was being discussed on the
TV we then get this scene where Taro
runs over to Mira's house and shows him
the death eraser and they then bring
everyone back to life and they go to the
police when they get to the station they
then explain basically everything that
happened except for one Cru cral detail
Taro never mentions that he had his own
death note for himself the only Death
Note they talk about is the one that Mi
has and eventually you know the police
understand what happened and they burned
the notebook and presumably they burned
the Eraser as well so that nothing like
this can ever happen again of course
like I said Taro kept his notebook a
secret and 7 years later we see that
ryuk is still with him which means that
I guess they must have been doing some
entertaining stuff otherwise ruk
probably would have killed him and some
somehow Death Note has become a movie
and TV franchise and we know this
because as they're walking down the
street we literally see a poster for the
Death Note movie up here not to mention
there was civilians talking about how
it's also a TV show as well and then in
the final page of the draft we see that
there's a Death Note manga as well so
clearly someone found out about the
Death Note maybe it was miora or someone
else and they literally just went to
town they made it into possibly the
biggest franchise in the world I am kind
of interested interested to know what
direction this would have gone um like
who is the author of this franchise and
why but yeah in terms of their ratings
for tarot I'm going to give him a 2.5
out of five potentially it could be
higher depending on what him and ryuk
got up to during that seven-year time
skip but given that we don't know
anything about what they did I'm just
going to give him a 2.5 because he did
make some mistakes but he did also fix
all those mistakes with the death eraser
and he also managed to trick everyone
into believing that there was only one
notebook where in reality there were two
and you know he's the one who had the
second one when it comes to MOA I'm
giving him a 1.5 out of five the reason
for that is that he panicked at being a
suspect and killed the investigators
while he was still in the classroom like
just making it super obvious and on top
of that he killed him even though he
knew he was innocent cuz remember the
whole reason why he killed him in the
first place is that he thought he would
be a suspect in their deaths but it was
Tara who killed them so Mira didn't even
kill them initially but he killed killed
them again to make sure that he wouldn't
be a suspect for killing them the first
time it's just super dumb and on top of
that he also killed the innocent
panelists on live TV just because they
were kind of maybe getting close to
discovering that a boy was responsible
even though they never would have found
him um so yeah I just felt like
sometimes he acted a bit too
irrationally the one positive is that
similar to light he did actually have a
goal and the reason I say that is
because in the manga there was this
panel here where it said that heinous
criminals all over the world have been
dying one after the other so clearly
Mor's I guess his ideology was similar
to lights in certain ways lastly the
unknown person who killed all his
colleagues with the death note he gets a
zero out of five because even though we
don't know much about him just from what
we know I don't see any redeeming
qualities at all with that one so yeah
the unknown person whatever his name is
he gets a zero out of five now switching
over to the main series the first person
we have to give a rating to is of course
Light Yagami aka the original original
Kira out of every person who used the
Death Note light by far had the biggest
Global impact evidenced in the years
after his death when we learned that he
reduced crime by 70% and ended Wars as
well additionally even though nobody
knew that light was actually Kira the
fact is that his actions led to a kind
of like a domino effect where now the
subject of Kira is taught in schools his
power was recognized by governments and
he has armies of religious followers
waiting for him to return in terms of
how used The Notebook initially he
started off with the intention of
wanting to make the world a better place
but it didn't take very long for him to
develop a massive God complex as he was
literally going around describing
himself as the god of the new world
within just 5 days of getting the death
note he murdered countless violent
criminals around the world technically
making him a serial killer although his
justification at the time was that it
was all for the benefit of society to
light's credit he was actually willing
to die for this ideology cuz when ryuk
showed up there was that scene where
light basically said to him that he was
expecting rute to come and that he
thought his soul was about to be taken
so that kind of shows you that he did
really truly believe in what he was
doing to the extent where he was willing
to give up his soul for a few days you
know for five days of just killing
criminals however whether you agree with
his ideology or not the point where he
objectively crossed the line is when he
began killing innocent people who
happened to get in his way the first
instance of this was when he murdered
Lind L Taylor who was a guy that was
pretending to be L although you could
argue that Lind was a death row inmate
the fact is the light believed that Lind
was The Real L meaning that in his mind
Taylor wasn't guilty of any crimes but
still light felt zero remorse and by the
look of it he even got pleasure out of
seeing Lynn's lifeless body broadcast on
the TV what this shows us is that light
was corrupted by the Death Note almost
immediately he had poor control over his
emotions and his ego and he could be
provoked into making stupid moves this
is in contrast to someone like Aira who
wasn't motivated by pride in any way and
kind of executed his plan without
letting his emotions get the better of
him throughout the main series light
then went on to kill several more
innocent people for his own personal
gain including a dozen FBI agents the
head of the Japanese police El waty and
uh yeah not to mention he also killed a
ton of minor criminals whose crimes
didn't deserve the death penalty as the
series continued he displayed even more
psychopath IC traits proving himself to
be a master manipulator ruthless and
sometimes just plain evil what can't be
denied though is that light did study
the laws of the death note in more
detail than any other user and he used
them to his benefit in ways that only he
could think of some of the best examples
of this were the times he took advantage
of the rules related to ownership and
also the rules related to memory loss
and he Ed those to kind of engineer
situations where his enemies would get
wiped out and he would just seem like
the perfect innocent light that he was
pretending to be overall when he
combined his deep understanding of the
rules with his ability to predict other
people's behavior light was able to keep
his secret under wraps for 6 years and
achieved his goal of a world with a lot
less criminal Behavior therefore despite
his many many many flaws and the fact he
had a super embarrassing death the
original K gets a 4.5 out of five
falling short of a perfect score due to
all of the downsides that I already
mentioned up next we have Ray pen who
was an FBI agent and was the only person
in this video besides tarot who used the
death note to kill multiple people
without even realizing it for a bit of
context about how this happened early on
into L's investigation he realized that
Kira had access to information from the
Japanese police this led to El
suspecting that Kira was either part of
the Japanese police or someone who was
close to someone within the Japanese
police and so for that reason he sent 12
FBI agents into Japan in secret and yeah
basically aam's doing investigation Ray
pamber was the person who was sent to
follow light and after following him for
a few days he came to the conclusion
that light was definitely not a suspect
in fact in episode 5 when light speaks
to Ray he realizes that he's not under
suspicion of being Kira and that most
likely Ray Pemba has no clue who he
really is but regardless he still
decides to kill Ry and all of the other
FBI agents as well the reason for this
is that his main target was L as we know
and so he knew that by killing the FBI
agents it would lead to a domino effect
in which L's identity would possibly be
revealed to the Japanese police the
problem for light though is that
although he knew Ray PM's name there
were still other FBI agents who he
didn't know about in Japan and so for
that reason he essentially confronted
Ray in a train station and forced him to
write down the names of his colleagues
to be specific light created a situation
in which Ray Pemba unknowingly had
pieces of the death note and as Ry was
writing down these names while looking
at the faces of his colleagues he was
the one who was killing them without
even knowing by the time Ray was done
the 11 other investigators were dead and
this massacre led to the NPA finding out
about El sending all these FBI people to
investigate them and their families when
it comes to the pros and cons of Ray
Pemba using the Death Note in the Pro
section there is literally nothing like
he didn't even know he was using it and
even if he did you know I mean he'd be
horrified he killed all of his
colleagues and his boss and you know
then he died as well so he gained
literally nothing from doing this
however when it comes to the downsides I
mean there are a ton of them um but one
of the main ones that sticks out is that
when he and light were talking light
said to him that if Ray did everything
he wanted light basically promised him
that ry's wife would be safe and Ray's
wife is of course Naomi misora and then
as we found out later like killed her
regardless for those reasons he gets a
zero out of five because there is
nothing redeeming about this uh it's
just just sad moving on to Misa man this
is another character who you could argue
was a porn of Kira um but I guess in her
case she wanted to be that so I guess
it's fine as a quick overview before we
met Misa as a character her parents had
been killed by some I guess just a
random murderer and for some reason that
person wasn't convicted or at the very
least the trial was taking a really long
time and people starting to think that
maybe he might be innocent but then Kira
swoops in and kills the killer anyway
which has led to mis's obsession with
whoever Kira is following that she was
then gifted a Death Note of her own by
the Shinigami RAM and her main goal was
to find out who Kira was and just do
whatever he wants given that she had the
power of the notebook as well as the
Shinigami eyes she managed to convince
everyone in society except for El that
she was the real Kira and the reason she
pretended to be him was that she knew it
would get his attention with help from
her Shinigami eyes she was gradually
able to track light down to his address
and following that she did whatever he
wanted for years and this included
harving her lifespan for a second time
which was ridiculous like who who does
that who harves the LIF band two times
it didn't make any sense for a normal
person but she was clearly obsessed with
him to a level that I don't think even
he could believe some quick facts about
Misa is that she's the only character in
the series to have two Shinigami fall in
love with her and willing to die for her
which is an amazing achievement to be
honest another thing is that she's the
only person to make the Shinigami ideal
twice as we already mentioned she also
had her memory of the Death Note
completely erased on two separate
occasions and by the end of the series
she has no recollection of it and no
powers in terms of the pros and cons
there are actually quite a few Pros here
and the first thing I wanted to say is
that when she made that plan with the
tapes it was really well thought out
like it it was a good plan and when she
went to ayama to find out who Kira was
she disguised herself perfectly in a way
that no one else would recognize what
she looked like so those were all good
things she was clearly intelligent to a
certain extent she also used her
Shinigami eyes to lights Advantage which
is exactly what she wanted to do and
during the years in the time skip she
was the one killing criminals on Kira's
behalf there was also that scene in part
two of the anime where she pretended to
be Kira on the phone to light's dad and
you know she was intimidating she did
exactly what she needed to do so she was
a useful character when we considered
that her goal was to be helpful to light
in any way possible she definitely did
fulfill that role however there are
still quite a few drawbacks and the
first one that sticks out to me is that
she was the one who gave away the
existence of Shinigami possibly her
worst mistake though was leaving
physical Clues on the envelopes that she
sent in when she was pretending to be
Kira the main point is that the police
were able to physically link Misa to the
envelopes of the second K and you know
that's why L never gave up on the idea
that she was the second ker and that
light was the first ker because there
was evidence there was physical evidence
another bad thing is that she couldn't
remember L's real name even though she'd
seen it and to be fair this is not as
easy as it sounds because you know she
sees tons of people's names every day
but still this was the one name that was
so so important and if she had
remembered it then they could have
killed him so much earlier than they did
finally the last downside I want to
mention is that one of the main things
that annoys me about Misa is that it was
very obvious the whole time that light
didn't like her there was even that one
panel in the manga when he was thinking
about killing her on the spot there were
just so many times that light made it
very clear he doesn't like her and I
guess he was just hoping that over time
that would change but let's be real even
in all that time he did not give a crap
and partly it's because he's gay but you
know there's other factors that play as
well like he just doesn't like her as a
person I don't think he just used her
and I guess she was happy to be used so
it's not really a negative if she's
happy with it but still I just thought
it was strange that she never got the
hint after all that time that's why
overall I'm giving Misa a 3.5 out of 5
but I'm especially interested to see
what you will think about this in the
comments down below do you think she
should be lower or higher this was a
difficult one to rate so uh yeah I'd
appreciate your input on Misa following
this the next person to have the death
note was higuchi otherwise known as the
third Kira and he's the type of person
who like specifically wanted to have the
notebook during the first half of the
anime there was a moment where Misa was
captured by L and REM kind of pressured
light into getting her released as soon
as possible and so his plan was to give
the notebook to a person who has high
status and loss for power and money he
knew that that type of individual would
try to use the notebook to gain even
more power and yeah after a long search
REM eventually found higuchi what's
funny about higuchi though is that
although he works for yotsuba which is
this massive conglomerate the fact is he
himself isn't very smart and so he
needed seven other Executives to help
him make the decisions about who they
were going to kill every week they all
had meetings to decide which business
person they were going to kill and how
that killing would affect the the stock
of yotsuba and to their credit you know
working together they were able to
increase the stock of yotsuba and
apparently all of their salaries
increased as well so there was
definitely a benefit but if you look at
this panel here it's clear that there
are certain Executives who would have
been able to use the Death Note by
themselves they were smart enough to not
need help whereas huchi you know he
wouldn't have had any success had he
tried to do this by himself and his
colleagues know that which is why they
were able to work out that it was him
some quick facts about higuchi is that
when REM offered him the death note she
did so on a certain condition that he
would still have to kill criminals who
appear on TV and this was to give the
appearance that Kira was still active
while obviously light and Misa were
locked up so the whole idea behind this
plan was that higuchi would do the
killings of criminals while light and
Misa were in a position where they
couldn't be responsible and so it kind
of showed that they were innocent and
besides that he which was free to use
the Death Note in any way he wanted
throughout the series remen described
him as a violent pathetic human being
and a disgusting fool and it was implied
that not only did he want to marry Misa
and have a trophy wife but there was a
comment in the anime where he said that
he was planning to kill her at some
point you know after he marries her so
that he could get some life insurance
money but it just goes to show you like
how much of a bad person he actually is
in terms of the pros and cons one of the
good things from their perspective is
that by working with the other
Executives they increase yotsu stock by
killing other Business Leaders when it
comes to the drawbacks though there are
a lot of them I mean one of the first
ones is that he made the Shinigami ideal
but even despite doing that he wasn't
able to escape being captured and killed
on the same day so yeah wasn't a good
day for him um another thing is that he
revealed he was Kira to Misa ammane and
essentially he was tricked by her which
is a massive
L not to mention he was so disliked by
the other Executives that they fully
work together to you know participate in
L's plan to take him down in the end
higuchi had almost no redeeming
qualities as a human and as I've said a
million times he wasn't smart enough to
use the notebook by himself which is a
big minus like that is something I can't
rate you that highly if you can't use
the notebook on your own and so for all
those reasons that we've already
mentioned I'm giving him a two out of
five after him we have L who doesn't
need any introduction but I know some of
you might be wondering why he's in this
video in the first place as we saw
previously with Akira to be on this list
you don't necessarily have to kill
someone with the notebook and like we
saw with Ray Pemba you also don't need
to have full ownership of the notebook
as well in L's case he falls into both
of those categories in that he never
killed anyone with it and he was never
the official owner however most
importantly he had physical possession
of the notebook and had the full
intention of using it following
higuchi's death L maintained his belief
that light and Misa were the first two
kiras and he was suspicious of certain
clues that light had left behind in
order to prove that they were guilty the
first thing El had to do was to show
that the 13-day rule in the notebook was
fake this 13-day rule was an idea that
like came up with which said that a user
of the notebook has to write at least
one name every 13 days from the moment
that they write the first name in the
book given that light and Misa were
locked up for 50 days with no access to
any notebooks it meant that if this rule
was real they couldn't be Kira as a
consequence of this with the exception
of L everyone else believed that these
two were now completely innocent and so
in episode 25 L decided to test his
theory his plan was that the Death Note
would be transported to a foreign
country where a criminal on death row
would write down a name if that criminal
then survived for the next 13 days it
would prove that the 13-day rule was
fake putting light and Misa back under
suspicion the case against Misa was
especially strong due to the forensic
evidence and all of the agents agreed
that if they found Kira that person
would have to be executed From rem's
perspective this was the worst thing she
could hear because by this point she was
basically in love with Misa and so to
stop it from happening she did the one
thing that Shinigami could never do and
she killed one human to extend the life
of another knowing that El's plan would
100% lead to Misa being captured and
killed she wrote his real name in The
Notebook and therefore extended misa's
lifespan in the process REM turned to
dust given that Shinigami aren't meant
to save humans and this technically
makes L one of the few people to at
least indirectly kill a Shinigami
overall I'm giving l a three out of five
given that his plan would have succeeded
if not for Magical factors outside of
his control cuz there was no way for him
to know that REM was in love with Misa
like it's impossible to make that
connection uh and so for that reason I'm
going to be generous and give him a
three also because he's my favorite
character as well so I just felt like
being generous now once REM disappeared
it's important to note that she left
behind two separate notebooks one that
originally belonged to her and a
separate one that belonged to a agami
called Sido sido's Death Note was the
first one that dropped to Earth and it
was kept in the possession of the
Japanese police following huchi's death
following the time skip it then
exchanged hands at least five times
before finally going back to its
original owner Sito who came back down
to earth to get it back when it comes to
this story line the version in the manga
is significantly different from the
version in the anime but seeing as the
Manga version is more interesting we're
going to talk about that version and
specifically all five characters who
possessed or used The Notebook those
five people are Melo Cal Snider y 462
Dwight Gordon and suo Yagami who
technically had ownership for a very
short time an interesting fact is that
although it was never shown in the anime
Melo having control of this notebook
directly led to the US president going
offline and to explain how let's do a
quick overview of the whole plot okay so
as we know El was from a place called
wham's house which is basically an
orphanage for super gifted children and
it was clear that he was by far the
smartest one out of all of them however
when he died they had to make a decision
about who was going to be his successor
and it came down to these two kids which
is Melo and Nia between the two of them
they were basically on the same level
with Nia possibly being slightly smarter
than Melo but the fact is regardless of
who was clever L hadn't made a final
decision on which one he preferred for
that reason Melo felt like he had
something to prove to show that he
should have been the one and so he
leaves wham's house and basically him
and Nia get into this battle to see
who's going to catch Kira first over the
next 3 years Nia then begins his own
investigation from scratch given that
all of L's data was erased and what ni
discovers is that there is a notebook of
death and it's likely in the hands of
the Japanese police meanwhile at the
same time Melo joins up with the mafia
in America and he sends a spy to join
Nia's investigation team from this spy
Melo also learns about the notebook in
the Japanese police and as a result he
puts a plan into motion where they
literally kidna the director of the mpa
melo's goal goal in doing this was to
pressure the mpa into trading The
Notebook that they have for the director
but like being light he doesn't want
anyone else to have the notebook and so
he uses his own death note to kill the
director despite that melow refuses to
give up and in retaliation the next
person he kidnaps is SAU Yagami aka the
daughter of the new director of the mpa
and the sister of Kira in a situation
like this light isn't able to kill her
in the same way he killed the director
given that that is literally his sister
and so reluctantly he does transfer
ownership of this notebook to his dad in
order to get his daughter back his dad
then hands it to one of the kidnappers
with this strong desire to let it go and
according to this panel doing that means
that ownership transferred again to this
random guy from the mafia although we
don't know this guy's real name his code
name was y 462 and after testing The
Notebook on three separate people in the
manga he eventually Escapes in a
helicopter the mafia's plan was to
distract Everyone by having y 462 go in
this helicopter while the real notebook
was in a missile that ended up being
blasted in a separate Direction y 462
then gets mercilessly blown up by the
head of the mafia Dwight Gordon and
following this moment the missile takes
the death note to an unknown location
Cal Snider was then the first person
from the mafia to pick it up and given
that y 462 was dead touching it first
made Snider the new owner the mafia then
used the notebook to wipe out 99% of
Nia's investigation team and this was a
genius move for two reasons number one
one it slows down Nia and gives Melo the
advantage in the race to catch Kira and
number two they killed the spy who was
working for them so that Nia wouldn't be
able to track them following all that
Melo then calls up the president of the
United States and threatens to control
him using the Death Note in particular
he tells the president that if he
doesn't do what he wants he's going to
write his name in the death note and
force the president to launch a nuke
therefore beginning World War II to stop
this from happening the only option the
president is given is that number one
the the mafia gets a pardon number two
they get funding from the government
number three they get weapons number
four they get access to satellite
cameras and finally number five they get
information on Nia's movements with the
spk on the phone the president does
agree to all of this since he doesn't
want to be killed but immediately
afterwards he calls up light for help
working together light and the president
organize a team of 30 men to attack
melo's base and get the notebook back
and I should also mention that just like
the anime Misa uses her eyes to
manipulate C Snider into sending them
melo's address the 30 soldiers then
arrive at melo's base to you know carry
out their mission however by this point
Sido has entered the equation like I
said before the notebook that the mafia
has originally belonged to Sido and so
he came back down to earth to literally
get it back because otherwise he's going
to die pretty soon he needs to start
killing humans to gain more life the
reality is though he didn't really have
a plan for how he was going to get it
back from the humans and so for a while
he was just doing whatever mellow when
the gang told him to do what this meant
is that number one they told him to
stand guard of their base and so when
the soldiers swooped in Sido made a move
and basically removed each of their
helmets one by one this then exposed
their faces to the CCTV cameras and it
just so happens that in a completely
separate room Melo Cal Snider and Dwight
Gordon they were all watching these
events unfold by this point Dwight had
literally forced Cal Snider at gunpoint
to make the IDE deal with uh with Sido
and so because of that Cal was able to
see their names however the group
clearly didn't trust Cal which is why
he's handcuffed in this panel although
it's possible he's handcuffed because
they found out that he sent the letter
of the address to Misa although this
isn't confirmed either way regardless
the fact is that Cal has the Shinigami
eyes and so he reads out the names of
all the 30 soldiers while Dwight writes
their names in The Notebook the gang
then leave the area and escape to a
different location and after finding out
that the plan failed the president
commits s because he's afraid of what
Melo might do as a side note it's also
heavily implied that light was the one
who made him do this by using the
notebook and I guess one reason he would
have done this was so that the president
couldn't be manipulated by Melo in the
future overall for the way they use the
death note I'm going to give the mafia a
three out of five collectively but let's
just quickly break it down on an
individual level so when it comes to Y
462 he personally gets a two out of five
and the reason for this is that you know
his goal for for using the death note he
wanted to essentially wipe the Slate
clean apparently he had done some bad
things in the past and so the boss was
angry at him and so he thought that by
doing this it would make up for his past
mistakes so what we know for sure is
that he didn't make up for those
mistakes given that the boss killed him
anyway uh and so that's one of the
reasons why he gets such a low rating
however the reason he does still get a
two at least you know he does still get
something is because he used the
notebook in a way that was useful to the
Mafia the reason we know this is because
number one he proved to them that the
notebook was Real by testing it out and
number two he erased all traces of their
crime of stealing the notebook because
in the manga he killed the pilot of the
airplane who was uh someone who was
working for them and he also killed the
other guy who made light's dad go on the
plane so those were the two people that
could possibly be investigated by the
police and he killed both of them so
there was no way for them to track down
Melo in the gang moving on to Cal Snider
he gets a 2.5 out of five given that he
was even more useful because he had the
Shinigami eye if it wasn't for him they
never would have survived the first raid
however Cal does have many drawbacks the
first being that he was the one who gave
away their location in the first place
because of that it's hard to work out if
Cal was an asset or a liability cuz he
was helping the mafia but at the same
time he was also seriously hurting them
as well there's also the fact that when
he made the ideal Dwight promised him
that he'd become the right-hand man of
of the mafia and that clearly wasn't the
case you know they didn't trust him they
had him handcuffed so he was lied to and
basically just used speaking of Dwight
he's the one who physically used the
notebook to get rid of the 30 soldiers
and the authors of Death Note described
him as the most evil character in the
story I decided to give him a three out
of five because he was very efficient
when it came to using the notebook in
that he forced other people to make the
ideal on his behalf lastly Melo also
gets a three out of five and and this
was disappointing because he had
potential for a five out of five like
his plan was perfect you know the way he
got the death note it was amazing not to
mention that if his threat to the
president had worked and if he had
gotten all of those demands yeah that
definitely would have been a five out of
five but the fact is you know he was
betrayed by Sido he was outsmarted by
Kira twice and forced to flee his base
without the notebook he had to blow up
his face in the process and also his
threat to the president didn't work like
the second they finished their phone
call the president was on the phone to
light so even though Melo had good ideas
nothing worked in the end when it came
to when it came to this specifically and
so yeah for that reason I have to give
him a three out of five but I wish I
could have given him more anyhow moving
away from the mafia and back to the
Japanese police there's one character
here who had full ownership of the
notebook for a short period of time and
I honestly had no idea about this like I
watched the anime I never really read
the Manga for Death Note until I made
this video and so when rereading it you
find out that in chapter 72 Hideki eay
did have temporary possession of the
notebook to be specific The Notebook
that eeday had was the one that was
given to them by Kira in the post and
the reason they chose eeday to have
ownership was actually kind of Genius
for a bit of context Kira had sent the
Japanese police The Notebook because he
wanted them to use it in order to get
the other one back from Melo and so In
This Moment light's dad was the one who
volunteered to take ownership and make
this Shinigami ideal as well however
eday points out that it's possible that
because the director is so well known if
he takes ownership of the notebook then
someone on melo's team like like for
example Cal Snider if they see a picture
of light's dad then they'll know he owns
a Death Note the reason for this is that
if someone owns a notebook you can't see
their lifespan above their heads if you
have the Shinigami eyes and so yeah
eeday was just warning everyone that if
melo's team has someone like that then
it's possible if not likely that they'd
find out that light dad has a Death Note
before the raid happens for obvious
reasons that could be a security risk
since they might just end up killing
lights dad before before the raid even
happens and so yeah for that reason
light decides that eeday should be the
one to take ownership since in his words
eeday is least likely to be known by
Melo in terms of a rating I feel like it
would be rude for me to give him one
just because he didn't do a single thing
with it except take ownership um but if
I had to give him one five out of five
just because he did do what he was
supposed to do and by taking ownership
he did kind of protect the director uh
so yeah five out of five I suppose
probably the least deserved five out of
five in history up next is of course suo
Yagami and in terms of the pros and cons
he does actually have quite a few Pros
to his name the first being that he was
the one who found out melo's real
identity thanks to his Shinigami eyes he
was able to see and tell everyone else
that melo's real name was mile kale and
that information was incredibly helpful
to light later on when his underlings
were able to use it to kill Melo once
and for all additionally it was him who
volunteered to make the Shinigami ideal
in the first place even though Matt
wanted to do it and I guess you could
say that was him being Noble like he
always is as definitely out of all the
characters he was the one with the
strongest moral compass on a similar
note it's very relevant that because of
his strong will he refused to let go of
the death no under any circumstances
because when you know when Melo and the
Gang had basically attacked him and he
was in a very vulnerable position even
then he still wouldn't let it go he just
was so determined to make up for his
mistake of giving it to them in the
first place that being said a large
factor in all of these ratings I've done
is basically how useful was the death
note to the person who was using it and
did they use it in a way that you know
benefited them a lot and when it comes
to lights dad I would say 100% yes
because due to his ownership of the
death note and the Shinigami eyes he
finally confirmed to himself that light
wasn't Kira up until that point light
was one of the biggest suspects there
was in the Kira investigation and it
must have been playing in the back of
his mind the entire time about whether
his son could actually be the mass
murderer that he'd been investigating
for all this time it was thanks to him
gaining the death note and the Shinigami
eyes that he was able to finally confirm
once and for all that his son was
innocent because when he looked at light
he saw that above light's head he could
see his lifespan by default that meant
that light didn't own a Death Note even
though he did actually have one on him
in this moment but the fact is he didn't
own a Death Note and so from his dad's
perspective this meant that light was
100% innocent all along ryuk even goes
on to say that most people who use the
Death Note are cursed with Misfortune
but in the case of light's dad he died
believing that his son wasn't Kira so in
a way he was the first person to use
this thing who actually died happy for
that specific reason I'm giving light
dad a five out of five and this time
it's a real five out of five because
ultimately The Notebook was able to give
him the one thing he wanted more than
anything else in the world now we're
finally down to the last two characters
and those are terum mikami and yomi
Takata who are two of light's loyalist
followers and two people who acted as
Kira at a time when light literally just
wasn't able to do it himself in terms of
the good things we can say about them
for the most part when it comes to
mikimi he did think on the same
wavelength as as light and he took
actions that light likely would have
taken himself for example when he killed
demawa on top of that mikimi also had
great deductive reasoning which is why
he was able to work out that light
couldn't move freely and he also worked
out when light was in the room he just
you know for the most part he was pretty
intelligent and was able to uh fill in
the gaps when information was lacking
Takata was similar in that she was very
intelligent and shared the same morals
as K and light um although there were
some occasions when both mikimi and
tarda strayed from what light believed
and sometimes they would take things too
far like when they they put out the idea
that maybe innocent people would now be
punished by kiar if they were too lazy
for example like they did push the
boundaries a little bit um but for the
most part they all thought in the same
way one of the interesting things about
taker especially is that she had never
I'm assuming had never even thought
about killing someone before but when
like gave her the responsibility of
being Kira and killing criminals she
didn't really hesitate like At first she
was shocked but it's not like she ever
said to him I don't want to do this or
I'm not going to do this she pretty much
started doing it straight away which
proves I guess her loyalty to light her
loyalty to Kira and and he couldn't
really ask for anything more than what
she did like she ticked all the boxes
down until the very end even when she
was in this terrible situation she was
still going to follow his instructions
and kill criminals and kill Melo she was
definitely one of the most loyal people
he had because of everything we saw I
would personally give Takata a four out
of five when it came to using the Death
Note like she didn't make any mistakes
however the same cannot be said for
mikami even though he was clearly an
intelligent person the fact remains that
his mistake is ultimately what got like
killed and that mistake is that he had a
schedule that was so precise that if he
ever deviated from that schedule
everybody would know that something was
wrong I feel like if mikimi had acted
like a normal person the whole time and
wasn't so rigid with his schedule then
people wouldn't notice certain things
but it's the fact that every day he did
the exact same things in the exact same
order when he eventually deviated from
that that is what gave the game away to
be specific during the climax of the
story mikami knew that he was being
watched by near in the S spk and on top
of that he also had strict instructions
not to do anything until the final
showdown regardless when takato was
taken hostage mikimi made his biggest
mistake and he diverged from his normal
schedule to go to the bank where he
wrote her name in the real death note up
until then he'd been using a fake death
note because he knew he was being
watched which is the crazy thing he knew
he was being watched but he still went
to the bank and showed them where the
real death note was so that was just
dumb he also didn't test the death note
before the final showdown which was so
stupid because mikami knew that the spk
had tried to trick him already like he
already there was already one Death Note
fake death note that he was using that
got swapped out for another fake death
note so he knew that someone was
watching him and he knew that they were
willing to replace his death note with a
fake so at least it makes sense to just
try one more time before the final
showdown to make sure that the Death
Note you have is definitely real and he
didn't do that and that's ultimately why
he lost and it's why light lost so when
we remember that the whole reason light
gave him the death note was because he
was so intelligent and wouldn't make
mistakes like this you can only say that
mikami's time as the Death Note user
ultimately ended in failure and so for
that reason I'm giving him a two out of
five the errors were just way too fatal
to forgive that I will say though that
in the manga it was mentioned by matsa
that during the final showdown it's
possible that mikimi wasn't in control
of his actions because Nia was
controlling him with the death note now
this was just a theory of Mata but
obviously it was written you know the
author of Death Note wrote this for a
reason kind of putting it out there um
so it's possible that the mistakes
mikami made were not down to him it was
because he was being controlled by Nia
and if that was the case in that
scenario I would give mikimi a rating of
four out of five because up until the
moment he was being controlled if he was
being controlled he was perfect pretty
much he did everything he needed to do
but this is a theory at this point we
don't actually know if Nia really did
use the death note or not to to control
mikimi um but it is interesting that in
the manga mikimi was arrested and then
10 days later he died in mysterious
circumstances and nobody knows why and
then the death notes were of course
burnt by Nia so if Nia did write his
name down no one would ever know um so
it's interesting do you think Nia
cheated and used the Death Note because
if he did then technically that makes
him a Death Note user and if he did in
fact do what this theory is saying then
I would give Nia a five out of five
because simply put he won the game he
beat light um by using the Death Note
against him and not only that he covered
his tracks perfectly as well anyway
people I hope you enjoyed this list of
every Death Note user and before we end
the video I'd like you to do two things
number one I'd appreciate if you liked
subscribe as this video took ages to
make so I'd really really really
appreciate it if you've watched all this
way if you could just like And subscribe
and maybe share it as well if you're
feeling generous um and another thing I
want you to check out the Death Note
musical album that's coming out very
soon and the reason I say that is
because earlier this year in 2023 there
was the death note musical in London and
I had no idea about this but my friend
mentioned it to me and so we ended up
going and it was just so good and I have
to say the album is coming out this year
and I'm just mentioning it because I
know some people might not even know
that it's a thing because definitely
didn't know it was a thing so uh yeah
just check it out if you haven't heard
of it before thank you guys for watching
as always and until the next one peace
out